こんちゃーはじめさツアーデスクがぜば全行が実は2日間大阪に入ってくるんですけど
も
見てくれ宮副がねえんだいや深刻な問題ではこれはだがそれだからやら本当に選択
しばらくじゃなくていて行こう全部選択しようっていうんですよ全部選択してるんです
けど
旅行次来ませんでした僕はどうしたら大
坂でこのまま2日が過ごせるかと思ったんですけども人を思いついたわけです服を
買おうと夕食時の深夜にね友達のトーン気に入ったんですけどもうあの僕は思ったわけ
ですよなまま僕が普通に服をドンキで買ってもいつもと同じ服装になってしまうそれだ
から
人生
おもんないやろ思うなんやで
あそれで馬鹿にするわけである一緒にいたところで2人に服を買っていただきました
ありがとうございます友達2人とコーディネートしてもらった服を読み中2日目ときて
僕が普段着ないような服でショット大阪はネット楽しめればいいなと思っております
まだ中身見たいですけど1日目と2日目がこっちから来ましょう普通の一般の方が着る
ような普通ノックをセレクトし
たのでそのとおり着用していただければ ok です勝ったかこれで9寸の版つの
フィット感はどうですかねこれを避けをすることでて大阪の上品なマダム達がを見て
社長の所苦情しないか品のショップ心配したらどういうことでだけでこいつが選んで
くれた1日目なんですけどこちらですだけでいきましょうまずまじで緊張してるあれ
これで本当にチェンチますけど中で
ああいう2試作するたシンプルな靴下大大大アーチんプレイヤー半パンツァーフォー
vivi の攻めるちょっとルーディ t シャツそして
君に恋してるパンツ
一をがすっがこれ待ってこれ本当に多分いう中継されるタイプのえさ
ふんどしみたいになってます側時間がないでも気がいます
あるかめ吸ってるううううきうよ
えーマジでこれでいくのか鉱山見る分は大丈夫なんですけども
後ろで完全にもキッズ丸出しです素なんでこの長い家に秘めたるエロスおっさ
内に秘めたる予想さんそんなさせる負けん気が穴が早いかでしょ
初日はそんな[ __ ]
できます動機ですからねわりとなんかぽいなぁポイポイ普通にいそうだね
持っていたんだよ内海てみたいタイプのが気付いクリック生えてるけどちょっとこう
いう服装で早速大阪行ってみたいと思います
ちょいさしぶりに
まあ昔コンビニでバイトしてた時の上司の方にはいいまして
すごい気まずい空気が流れました大
やばいやばい私はございません
ani
ana
停止でもバカにやってい
あああああ
ni
me
サーブこれ
気合いれていきましたね試合に入れ方が違う人だけパソ
一応今まで4 n
ahaan
ni
ん
大阪府日目でございます&所と g バッグの穴の感じがすっごい嫌でピン際はですね
内に秘めた気持ちをしたがってすごい不快な1日になりました
いや2日目に京呉服ないからねで今日の凍っの音鈴大阪な履いてるわけ
とびっきりのコーデだよ応募のなレンジャー奈落こなせるでしょう
安産思いっきりローがゾッとしてください煽りまたその方できるように寒かったできる
ように
ではをただ黙ってきてなお姉てるぞという感じでございますありがとうです頼むよ
ホント編者のだったら本当に今後使える服かね個人的にありがたいんですけど
ウェルトでしたーー
をえっ
2ワッフルんちょっと身近なイカインクのシャツじゃあこれはヤバいでしょ
ずっと待って本当にこれで行くのはああやばい俺は直見たタンクトップヤッケ少ないん
でどうぞ応援できますけどねきますけどこれは町もアティしかねぇ
まず行くからでこれでイベント当日だろにすごいテーション下がったのはイベント調査
とイベント衣装があるのでそれは別なんですけどそこに行くまでの過程よ
ここだけ見ると女だねまぁ買っていただいたのはありがたいですこれで今日は大阪2日
目
いこうと思います
普通に読むエアーんだんじゃあ今日はのによく拭いだろ
うん
新書なんか勝ち越しだね
me
ああああああ
line
おっ
me
ん
ズってれるって
あーてるっててれるってるあああああってるって言ってる
a
aname